on va vous parler de l'autre côté
beaucoup plus noir on vous en parlait
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière où parler
qui avait une 9
surdose de drogue mortelle donc parce
que les trafiquants coupe la drogue avec
un produit extrêmement toxique ça
c'était la semaine dernière neuf on est
rendu à 15
michel marcellin
il ya une consommation d'héroïne dans
dans l'état qui ont précédé le décès dit
pierre lévesque qui dirige ce centre
pour toxicomanes est sous le choc après
le décès d'un homme dans un de ces 22
logements le week-end dernier la dose
normale d'héroïne que les gens vont
prendre lé pas si forte que ça a quand
on ajoute un produit comme le fentanyl à
l'intérieur du radio qui est 40 fois
plus fort qu'en doses d'héroïne normal
et donc on se retrouve un produit
extrêmement puissant et qui peut causer
justement des mets des morts subites
de morose à montréal comme ailleurs
difficile d'acheter de l'héroïne qu'il
soit occupé avec du fentanyl un
médicament d'ordonnancé souvent
fabriqués clandestinement la direction
de la santé publique de montréal on
invite les consommateurs à la méfiance
actuellement le danger est multiplié par
des produits qu'on retrouve dans les
drogues qui sont en circulation
donc c'est nettement plus dangereux
richard qui consomment des drogues
depuis l'âge de 12 ans reconnaît le
risque
plus dangereux pour la santé
absolument absolument moi plus que ça va
plus que je vois que ces pays c'est la
qualité
la qualité est vraiment
autant que ça peut être très puissants
comme ce sens autant que c'est nocif le
monde qui consomment aujourd'hui ne
savent absolument pas ce qu'ils prennent
guy pierre lévesque parce qu'on pourrait
sauver des vies en utilisant le noxon
dans les cas de surdoses ce médicament
est déjà utilisé dans les urgences mais
plusieurs souhaitent le voir plus
accessible ces produits-là
inverse donc inverse la situation a
causé par le passé temporairement et
donc ça donne la tâche commun d'avoir
les premiers soins car il les surdos
touche maintenant non seulement les
grands toxicomanes mais aussi les
utilisateurs occasionnels ici michel
marsolais radio canada montréal